Pulls over and like two days.
Nothing right now.
No.
And I could feel like,
um,
like my my butthole or you felt like,
have broken glass inside.
Oh,
that feeling.
So I finally,
I pushed too hard cause I,
I pushed it out like I was having a baby.
I was like,
I was doing lamaze and then not up on the youtube screen please.
So I fuck it.
She's up while he's talking cause and effect.
And then I'm pushed and I pushed and then like,
aw man,
I could just feel,
I saw like I wiped myself and it might the toilet paper,
like a fucking Tampon.
And I was in pain,
dude.
It says the veins around your anus tend to stretch under pressure and may bulge
or swell,
swollen veins,
hemorrhoids can develop from increased pressure in the lower rectum due to
straining during bowel movements sitting for long periods of time on the toilet.
And He,
Bravo has a hilarious bit about it being on his phone,
on his phone,
taking a shit.
It's very funny.
Remember,
did he talk about her on here?
I think you talked about it on here,
but it was crazy not good for your butthole to be sitting in that.
How would describe the feeling?
The pain?
It feels like,
um,
I remember talking about in a bit,
I said that it felt like every night though the goals sort of siloed by using me
like fuck you in the ass at night.
How many days did you go before he took a shot?
Or three days that then I took the shit.
That's when the pain started and I blew my butthole out I guess.
And then like three days later I,
there's shit right without paying for like two weeks while I'm afraid of fucking
neat man.
I have a friend of mine had to go to a doctor and they had to literally break up
to shit in his butt hole there to go up as bottle with an instrument and break
it up and flush them out,
get him something.
I think he had to take something,
some sort of diuretic and some stool loosening agent,
like some hardcore drugs.
And then they had to go in there with like a chisel and chop off this concrete
log that he had at the bottom of his bottle.
And then he,
you know,
he hadn't shit in many strive to.
Yeah,
it was dangerous and he couldn't get it out.
So he was literally plugged up and it kept piling it.
It's not like he's going to stop eating,
it's just going to keep piling in.
So he's got a blockade of like shit rocks at the end of his booty tunnel and
it's,
it's a real product can be bad.
It's a real problem.
He had to go to a doctor.
My aunt like finally came out and then clink,
clink.
But it was all bad.
It was all dry with ugly man.
Painful.
You gotta eat your vegetables.
He'd,
every time I peed and after I finished paying,
it was hurting my butthole or threat.
Peed.
Yeah.
I mean
that's one thing that I freak out about people that are on this carnivore diet.
I hear this carnivore diet stuff and they're like,
oh no,
no problem.
Shutting it off like no problem at all.
You don't eat any vegetables,
you've got no problem at all.
Who wouldn't really kill you to eat some Broccoli with a little Kale is a loose
in that motherfucker life line up.
I just can't imagine the Broccoli's killing you.
I think if Broccoli's killing you,
there's probably something else wrong you should probably like get your blood
work done for.
I'd figured out what the vitamins are.
If you eat broccoli and you start getting headaches Bra,
he broccoli folks with my gains.
I eat broccoli,
I get a headache.
Sure man.
People have been eating broccoli forever.
Like how's that possible?
Like what?
When did Broccoli ever become something that you,
you feel shitty after you ate?
Has anybody ever said that like,
I eat broccoli.
It just fucking get headaches.
If folks over my immune system dudes will claim that now these carnivore guys,
a lot of them are claiming like,
I,
I eat a fucking salad bro.
I'm,
I'm off for a while.
People attempt to then back at the other way.
In general,
Broccoli is safe to eat.
Any side effects are not serious.
Most common side effect is gas or bowel irritation.
Yeah.
Broccoli farts caused by Broccoli's high amounts of fiber.
All cruciferous.
It's a great word.
Cruciferous vegetables can make you grassy.
Oh,
gassy accrue SIF.
I like how you said Gassy,
gassy.
Are you a scientist or nine?
You fuck.
Okay.
When you're a scientist,
you scientific terms,
you don't say gassy with me,
but he scares saying farts.
Gassy.
But the health benefits outweigh the discomfort.
Yeah,
so there's certain people like,
um,
that I think have a real physical issue.
Like Jordan Peterson is one of them.
When he describes like he,
he literally can't have anything other than me and at this point in his life or
it gives them headaches and it fucks with them.
I think certain people may,
all bullshit aside,
might have a real biological issue with vegetables,
which sounds insane,
but it only makes sense.
People have a problem with everything.
There's certain people that have a problem with almost everything that people
that are allergic to citrus as people that are allergic to certain now Cahtos
all kinds of plants.
There's people that are allergic to grass.
Why wouldn't be,
hey,
be allergic to some vegetables,
so if you are allergic to some vegetables and you just go on an all meat diet,
all those symptoms of those allergies go away.
Why wouldn't that make sense to people?
I mean they're everyone.
There's so many people fighting off the idea of this carnivore diet that you're
only eating meat and you feel fantastic.
You're probably dealing with a bunch of people that have undiagnosed
interactions like a net negative in interactions with vegetables.
They just,
it's probably something about their system that does not go well with
vegetables,
so they should take vitamins.
I take vitamins and eat meat and you better find a way it gets a pri fiber.
Kids didn't want to get all backed up.
Vegetables are good.
I think if you eat like a really fatty meat though,
you don't have that problem.
If you eat like a ton of rib eyes,
it just greases up that whole pipeline and you're like,
whew,
everything comes a flying out.
I think when you start eating that lean ground bison meat,
no butter,
like you're going to have a problem.
But butterball,
yeah,
he chew that shit down and pack it down.
Then you water on top of it.
So it's got like you got like the pack dot bison here and then he got the water
behind it.
It's concrete a it.
Oh it's way through your body.
Have some broccoli,
bro.
Put some cheese on it.
Some people really firmly believe that dairy is bad for you.
And that's something I've never tried.
I've never tried to do it.
Had dairy.
No,
no,
no.
To not have dairy.
I've never tried to like way off.
Hundred percent dairy.
I don't eat much,
but if I do,
it's mostly cheese.
Hardly ever drink milk unless it's with cookies.
And whenever I do,
I always feel weird if I a milk,
I shouldn't myself,
I've been my whole life tolerant or intolerant and I didn't even know that.
My mom never told me,
but man,
every time I have eating cheese I have probably get stuffed off.
It'll come out to him.
So I fuck with almond milk and soy milk now.
Yeah.
Do you fuck with Vegan cheese?
I publish everything big.
Only meat no more.
When did you stop?
But why wouldn't have fuck my ass hole blew up.
That's good.
Move.
Cause fucked up the fiber.
And so you feel good though.
You feel me?
I'm still fat.
People don't believe me.
They theory Vegan.
You're fucking fat when you eat crops.
W why are you opposed to eggs on?
No,
just uh,
just give it all up,
man.
I got so scared after right?
I started bleeding,
man.
And I said,
you know what?
Get your diet on point.
If you feel better.
I feel good.
Yeah.
I mean I don't have,
I don't have the runs.
I don't got shit on myself anymore.
You ever try out this other t types of diets or is this the first one?
No,
I try to be in the Vegan.
I tried the Atkins Diet.
I tried,
um,
the Hollywood diet.
You know when you wake up in the morning and do some coke,
and in part of that one,
now this sucked.
Don't,
sorry.
Never try that one.
Yeah.